hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play orbiter okay
now this is a game that I saw at PAX and
I actually had a long talk with a
developer about it this game is like it
was amazingly cool when I saw it just
the soundtrack and the gameplay and the
graphics and everything about a told me
that this game was three years in
development but it like gotten hardly
any attention out I couldn't imagine why
because it just looks so darn cool and
if you don't see what I'm talking about
like right now you will in a little bit
because it gets even crazier okay so I
played it a little bit and what happens
is you are oh holy God okay so you are
this little orbiter guy and what you
need to do is you need to start orbiting
things and collect points it's a very
freeform adventure there's a lot a lot
of objective to it but the soundtrack is
just absolutely astronomical I love it
and loved games with a great sound right
so you can hit the Z button to slow time
down so that you can time your orbit and
as you can see you slowly steadily
collect points and you can bounce off
objects and collect energy and I
actually don't know a lot of the
mechanics to it because I mean I didn't
really get an in-depth play through the
game at PAX so this is kind of my first
time actually playing it as sort of just
on my own and free for me so this little
guy that you got here he is an orbiter
of some sort I'm not really sure
you go into these little spherical
bubbles which are like I mean I mean I
gotta say he told me that a lot of this
is just like graphical trickery like
every object here is actually
two-dimensional it just looks 3d because
of shading and colors or something like
that it's just incredibly well made like
hence the three year development cycle
and it's currently on a Kickstarter
right now I believe or it's on Steam
greenlight Kickstarter steam greenlight
one of those two anyway I'm hoping that
this gets it a bit more attention
because just so cool now anyway enough
blabbering let's get to the actual
gameplay here
so as you can tell I'm trying to go a
long thing and it's it's alrighty then
go nuts that I shall so then we just zip
off here into the next orb and sky is
just a series of things and this is I
think this is where I picked up the game
of whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
holy crap I don't even know what I'm
doing right now hang on hold on a second
I'm trying to do commentary here so what
I saw when I picked up the game before
here is that I don't know if there were
enemies or something or these little
probe thingies but you can see like
you're getting tight little orbitals
around things and you're just gonna jam
out to the soundtrack and just play the
game for yourself it's it's really cool
and you can see you got a score counter
up on the side there and oh no I died
how did I die I didn't even know you
could die well I guess you can die
that's the thing I didn't know about how
do i haha I died I got a restarted oh I
see there was a temp there was a
temperature bar over there on the left
alright so now I'm back in to playing it
again so let's uh let's not die okay so
wait no what's that temperature bar or
was I being mistaken I thought I saw a
temperature bar there
I either way okay so you got a velocity
bar on this on the bottom there and
there was another bar that I wasn't sure
what it did energy that's what it's ah
there was it was a temperature bar on
the side there so Lewis we're trying to
go whoops okay so you need to get a loaf
velocity to be able to escape of these
orbitals I think and as you can see I'm
like cranking up velocity on this thing
and the only way to get out of it with
knowing where I'm going is to use the
slowdown mechanic oh hello where'd you
come from
okay so ha ha ha oh man this game is
really cool
I mean I'm dead serious it's like one of
the coolest games I've ever seen because
basically I've never seen anything like
it it's just I mean you got try for
yourself the link is in the description
below just play this demo is totally
free even though it's trying to get on
Steam greenlight it's just trying to
show off so that you guys can get a feel
for what it's all about and in all
honesty I don't know what more lies
beyond this first area let me see if
there's actually any more that I can
find there cuz this is part of the area
that was a playable demo or at least the
part that I played in what is that I
have never seen that before ok never
mind then so I might be actually in a
new area here what the hell oh my god
this is so crazy holy crap
ok I'm trying to get in one of these ah
let me an ok there we go no let me in I
want in please please can I have in okay
the little green glowy things are things
that you collect for extra points it's
so crazy ok
alright then I'm just enamored by I'm in
Namur
yes mmm
enamored by these graphics I mean it's
just such a simple concept but it's so
well implemented got ya okay as you can
see okay I think boosting which you hold
down X to boost is uh what causes you to
a rise in temperature and potentially
destroy you so I'm trying to get back to
the other thing and I'm kind of just
where am I going
I'm trying to get back here wheel and
now I'm trying to exit to this one over
here no get over there
it's can now don't get caught in the
orbit I don't want to be in the orbit I
want to be I didn't I didn't ask for
this I didn't ask for this I asked to be
over there I see the cannot get out of
the orbit it not up I'm going off into
space or now I've escaped orbit I'm
going to die this is how I oh hello
hello hello just coming by for a little
kiss and then I'm going to go on my
merry way anyway okay let's see if we
can try this again there no come and let
me out let me out I'm a free bird let me
out please
all my temperature was going up yeah
there we go
okay sorry that took so long it was just
kind of a bit of an ordeal okay so I saw
something else in the packs demo that
was really interesting so you can get
one hello all right get over there into
that make it blow up just like so
collect more points I've got like over a
million points I don't know that whoa I
just got up to 300,000 more don't know
why see Ricky oh baby you can you can go
slow-motion anytime you want I don't
know if it actually does anything
besides make everything look really cool
holy crap once you're in an orbital I
think I kind of hold down X to charge up
and that causes them to blow up I don't
know if those are just like other
orbiters that I'm just killing I'm like
a mass-murdering orbiter right now I'm
just trying to kill every one hundred
yeah it's got to be it
I mean it's just like really freeform I
don't think that they gave me an
objective at all like what the thing
said it just said kind of go nuts
so that's all that I'm doing it's really
cool really cool whoo I can play this
for hours and just be messing around
with the physics of it where am I going
where's my gut goooood oh my god and
there's a Center one this was a center
thing at the beginning of the thing I
don't know if this is important it
doesn't seem like I can blow this one up
I've lost a lot of velocity so let's
just get out of here is there another
exit way no okay boost up a bit nope get
out of that let's go back nope can't
need more velocity see let's just I
think I can get more velocity by kind of
orbiting around the main circle and you
can see my temperature's rising quickly
so I need to stop being such a neighbor
there we go okay so there's got to be
another thing this looks like an actual
star here going do I get points by doing
that boy I actually get energy I don't
know if that's a good thing is it a good
thing I have no idea okay hang it good
day oh I was so close you lose key okay
that one's dead I collect the points
then that one blows up I collect the
points and there's got to be another
exiting orbital exit all orbital besides
the one that I came from sorry bear with
me for a moment I haven't oh there we go
right there it's huge I probably need a
lot of velocity so let me just crank up
for a bit going around this thing excuse
me Slenderman can we get an interview
okay got some points there and there
seems to be some sort of combo system
that I'm not taking advantage of come on
it is a bit tricky oh now don't slow
down Oh
huh I almost sploded all over the place
oh my goodness okay so how many have I
been
before oh no way not been to this one
this is where the thing is
oh okay never mind then where am I going
where am I going
I'm just afraid that I'm gonna get too
much velocity and just start veering off
into space okay so where this is where
there must have been some other one for
the pink one like up top because I
thought that I was at the other one for
a second there yeah come on come on go
go go go yeah all right there must be it
must be another one that one that one up
there I haven't seen that one before
gotta get there gotta get together getta
getta getta get the yes there we go this
is different and holy crap your orbitals
are a little bit strange there guys see
alright so let me just carry on to see
if there's any other whoa hello
sometimes I'll get like a direct
bullseye on these guys and I don't even
mean - these guys are tiny I can't even
get in orbit around them come on come on
come on it's me me markiplier do it for
me come on I'm popular on the internet
don't you know who I am
please please please let me orbit you
there we go okay okay so then I can
track into the next one up I'm a little
off good here we go then I can use my
tracker doodad oh oh oh hang on no no no
no I know this is getting absolutely
crazy but I'm hoping that this is
actually entertaining to watch because
it's so fun to play you guys got to try
it for yourself it's totally free this
demo is
it's available on the website linked in
the description below if I haven't
mentioned that already okay
so I've done all that I think I've
collected a lot of points I need to find
I don't know if like if I collect enough
points if it opens up another area I'm
not exactly sure
hello we try to find no doesn't look
like over there nope didn't mean to get
in that orbital whoa right so if I go
over here
no nothing over there I know I saw
someone at wouldn't someone else was
playing it there was a way to get to the
galaxy map and that's what I'm trying to
get to right now huh come on there we go
okay so there was the area down here
with these guys over here there's only
like one dude left and he's pretty much
escaping orbit where the Hecky heck do I
go I wish I could zoom out and see them
like a full map that probably is a way I
just don't know about it come here haha
can't escape me
hey bear ski all right I think that's
all the things over here did that open
up any other areas those little green
glowy things they run away from me why
are you running away from me well you're
running wait you're running a little guy
why are you running come back here
America come on come back they're like
little schools of fish you know like in
Call of Duty they run away or swim away
when you try to go near him
realistic Call of Duty fish simulator
god of duty
did anybody ever see the video I did a
cod of duty you know when I release a
video people freaked out they didn't
even watch the video or like oh I can't
believe Mar Blair sold out and played
call of duty call of duty call of duty
when in reality I was playing Cod of
duty and you guys just didn't realize it
so I mean that's all I have to say about
that now what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to find the next area come on let
me out let me out no don't don't splode
there's got to be another orbital
somewhere around here no don't splode
OOP no no like a little fish bobbing in
and out of the water
okay so I don't see any other orbiters
that means there must be something over
here unless this is all there is to the
demo whether that's the case I do not
know yeah yeah there we go
and let me well uh alarm sector blaring
I was about to die okay hang on there I
wanna I want to get to another area but
I just don't know where it is there we
go I haven't been actively trying to get
points see wait what is that hand is
like it this is a thing what is this
what am i doing whoa I slowed down way
too much oh I was going in the opposite
direction I was supposed to go whoops
that was my bad I apologize everyone I
saw I seem to have messed up everything
up kid man can you give me a boost
no all right fine screw you how did I
get out of here
there was a way out besides the big pink
thingy I know I came in here at least I
thought anyway oh boy I am going off
into space where am I
hello hello anything oh there we go I
just went away wide orbit around the
place
oh I I always listen to the censors way
too late what is that thing that's blue
I haven't seen that before what was that
what did I just get sorry I have no idea
what I'm doing
yep let me try to escape this way by
going this way
no nothing over there I don't think I
can legitimately escape but I can bounce
off to some of these things yeah okay
there we go I am at a loss now so I
think I'm coming to the end of this
particular let's play but if you like
what you saw
seriously give it a try it is absolutely
amazing and it's ugly cost any money to
vote it up on Steam greenlight so
hopefully this will be able to get more
attention because this was one of the
most creative things that I saw in packs
and I was like immediately eager to play
it so other than that I'm just gonna try
to get enough velocity to try to go
somewhere here which just kind of means
that I'm gonna go here until I splode
all over the place hang on bear with me
bear with me everybody aha I knew it I
knew there was uh something there I knew
there was uh something I knew it
oh whoops that's not I'm no stop
boosting don't die yep okay yeah no
don't go don't don't don't rebound it
it's like impossible for me to hit it
how did I hit it twice in a row good
no oh you keep hitting it it's tiny
alright so this is where I started up so
I'm gonna get maximum velocity and then
loud shout trip swoop keep going keep
going boost keep going
anything anything anything at all no
nothing nothing
dang it I thought that was gonna be some
alrighty then okay I think that's just
about it I don't believe that the demo
has the full galaxy mode that I saw at
PAX but either way it's still worth a
try it's incredibly fun like it's just
like oh now I'm slowing down way to go
way to go there buckaroo let me just get
enough speed and then I'm gonna shoot
off no not that way what are you doing
getting really this is how slow you want
to go really okay there we go okay
now I'm just gonna zoom off into space
ah those gate and now we're back here -
all right so that is it for orbiter
remember link in the description I think
I mentioned that like ten thousand times
now so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
yes
ah
I'm guessing that circle
good ass boy
why